elon musk likes being center stage in
everything he does are you guys having a
good time
and now musk's attempt to take over
twitter has certainly got everyone
talking about him elon confirming in his
first interview since the news broke
that he wants to buy twitter saying it's
not about making money but something
bigger having a public platform that is
maximally trusted and broadly inclusive
is extremely important
to the future of civilization
a week ago he bought a 9 stake in the
social media platform making him its
biggest shareholder but he wasn't done
musk broke the news appropriately on
twitter making an offer for 100 of the
company at
54.20
a share a total purchase of a little
over 40 billion dollars
in a letter to the company's board of
directors musk said twitter has extra
ordinary potential i will unlock it
elon musk has got very strong opinions
on on free speech you know on his uh
what he believes twitter needs to do to
fix the platform um and i think that
those are not necessarily aligned with
the majority of all the most typical
twitter users and so from that respect i
think this could be a bad day for
twitter users
musk has a love-hate relationship with
twitter with 81 million followers he is
an adept user of the platform and boasts
its potential but he's also been
critical of twitter's aggressive stance
at cancelling accounts of users it feels
promote misinformation even if that user
is a president last year twitter
permanently suspended the account of
donald trump
critics say a twitter takeover by musk
would be dangerous elon musk ought to
stick to cars and the twitter board
ought to reject this offer and we have
seen elon musk time and again spread
vaccine disinformation use the platform
to build his own wealth at the expense
of others and call on his troll army to
attack and harass people who disagree
with him
the u.s government charged musk with
securities fraud in 2018 for misleading
tweets that he sent out about his car
company tesla he agreed to settle and
pay nearly 40 million dollars in fines
but musk knows that his attempt to buy
twitter could bring similar government
scrutiny people shouldn't discount the
fact that you know this is the world's
richest man and he is having a lot of
fun here and he's enjoying it and it
could well turn out to be the biggest
tech prank that the world has ever seen
will the little blue bird have a new
owner it very well could if musk is
serious and gets his way which is far
from a sure thing
gabriel rosando al jazeera new york